are you ready Matt yes are you ready
Ryan don't throw the Garbage Pail DVDs
into the garbage male oh you missed that
up that's your life it's probably gonna
cost you now go pick him up pick him up
oh my god did you get Alba no no go pick
them up your bunch of garbage yourself
yes yes yes nobody should survive this
movie whoa man you are really really bad
at this it's almost like your life's on
the line or something that's cheating -
cheating it doesn't matter cuz Ryan love
anyway I'm the Nostalgia Critic and this
is pop quiz hotshot I'm the Nostalgia
Critic and ever since I was a child I
always want to play games quoting movies
and TV with my friends the only problem
was I had no friends well now that I
have power I can take my friends by
force with the help of my new pal
general anesthetic I can kidnap all the
friends I want and force them to answer
questions it might say by the Bell style
cent there will be laughs trivia those
disturbing cartoons that give you night
terrors but most of all there will be
fun the laughter and joy will last
however long I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
welcome to pop quiz hotshot where the
contestants are kidnapped the winner
gets money but the loser dies have you
think that's way too dark or intense
you're gonna love the rest of the
internet we have here Ryan
now Ryan it says here that you do a
bunch of various voices what was that
she hears your voice really breaking
there's your boys okay
it also says you do a very good
Chewbacca was that mating call maybe
very frightening well done and Matt Oh
Matty you you you have the proper
reaction you're supposed to have on this
show like yeah I gotta let's have fun is
fun but you have this the center of fear
yeah which I respect
just yes I like that and it also says
here that you brought dressed because
you had a crush on somebody yes I'm
gonna need to go into more information
about that this was a preschool and I
had a crush on a girl there and everyone
had to pick it roll in little of the
Goldilocks and the three bears
and so I wanted to be Goldilocks because
she was Goldilocks and they had us read
our lines in unison and it was very
creepy they're infested with cooties at
that age yeah god I knew this yes
but but you didn't care it was true love
it I loved my wig and we're gonna find
out even more about you unfortunately
once general anaesthetic goes up at the
rules each contestant is asked a series
of questions involving the sounds of
quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the nostalgia critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round 2 where the quotes
get even harder the winner with the most
points face off against the nostalgia
critic and a one-on-one match if the
contestant wins they walk out with a
cash prize and also their lives if they
lose the cash prize will be added to the
next contestants winning
alright are you two ready yes
meteor wig okay Ryan finished a line
from The Princess Bride never go in
against a Sicilian when you fail the
right direction well done Matt you have
a hard time topping that which animated
movie had the line teenagers they think
they know everything you give them an
inch they swim all over you it's Beauty
and the Beast Little Mermaid actually so
where was their swimming I'm just
kidding
Ryan hopefully a slightly less sexist
answer out of you just slightly though
slightly which live-action villain
originally animated on TV says the line
I am more than a man more than life I am
a god I'm Batman yes that's the name of
the character I'm Batman they they
actually said who are you
I'm I'm Batman that's what he always
said yes no it was actually Skeletor Ian
Masters of the Universe the movie that
would it be incredible piece about this
show I am a guide net finish this line
from grease
this car is automatic it's systemic its
hydra-matic
why it's it's prophylactic come on it's
gotta be I'll give you that because that
would have been a much better Lee it was
actually greased lightning okay Ryan
when Jack Dawson screamed I'm the king
of the world on Titanic
where was he standing on the doomed ship
the port the bow or starboard the bow
yes matte finish the line from the Dark
Knight
it's simple we flip a truck on a south
street clearly a Chicagoan but it's we
kill of the Batman which Dark Knight
Rises clearly did Ryan in the usual
suspects which characters said I believe
in God and the only thing that scares me
is Keyser söze
[Music]
uh-oh is that the mic yeah well no
wonder Donatello's kickin it hot look
there we whatever you were trying to do
was try it again
so one not played by Kevin Spacey that's
amazing
it actually was Kevin Spacey if you just
said the exact opposite of what you said
you would have gotten it right it was
verbal Kint played by Kevin Spacey very
good Matt's in The Addams Family which
character asked if Girl Scout cookies
are made from real Girl Scouts Pugsley
no supple Wednesday Oh any funny wife
and the kids is oh that's right Ryan who
was the actor in Casper who said the
line who you gonna call someone else oh
it's a Bill Pullman no dan Aykroyd
actually playing a gun buster you know
what but it's okay because I really like
how well you did that Kevin Moriarty boy
that was probably accurate Matt yeah
which movie had the line there's more to
life than the little money you know
don't you know that yes yes it is all I
wanted in double points for that vibe
that not going to Alice Ryan who was the
actress that said you're light
I'm not gonna pay for those in
spider-man 2 Emily Deschanel Chris and
Dunst or rosemary Harris rosemary Harris
no it's actually Emily Deschanel Steve
no she was in that movie or who she is
Matt in Fight Club what is the sixth
rule of Fight Club one fight at a time
no shirts no shoes or only two guys to a
fight only two you guys do a fight no is
actually no shirts no shoes we all know
about the second rule and you lose
anyway Thank You Ryan
which Nicolas Cage film has the screamed
line killing me won't bring back your
goddamn money you are missing a classic
Raising Arizona Oh
oh that's painful you are missing one of
the greatest Nicolas Cage performances
film
everything's ever Wicker Man and wicker
man you've got some never feels the same
- don't worry we'll reenact that torture
well yes ma'am
in big trouble a little China which
characters said I'm a reasonable guy
but I just experienced some very
unreasonable things
han Solo of course I'm sorry I've not
seen big trouble that's right you have
not seen I'm gonna go you're right
everybody does no Jack Burton when will
you ever get rid of those things okay
that was of course the spazzy attack and
it looks like Matt you have avoided it
which means Ryan
sadly you must pay the penalty is a
penalty of my choosing and since you're
so good at voices I want you to do a
very amusing one I want you to do babe
so we will get you in that outfit until
then Matt you get to watch the spazzy
cartoon you know maybe I am watching too
many films in fact maybe I'm watching
them so much that they're actually
coming to life around me you know with
the have vomiting there and stuff yes
that's the reaction that I have every
day watching those because I do watch
them every day because I like that taste
I'm very sick and Ryan you merely
adopted the de Stael job I was born in
it molded by it I think you're ready for
it let's move on to round two we will
begin with Matt which stanley kubrick's
movies last line was I was cured all
right dr. Strangelove eyes wide shut or
clap oh boy you know
take away all his point 7:10 that's a
pretty kick-ass movie is I've
learned so much for watching that movie
riot in its intro sequence The Twilight
Zone is described as a dimension of
sound sight and what alright I so wanted
to hear Bane answer this it's a the mall
mat in The King's Speech what the lines
nicknamed a Lionel Logue called King
George the sixth a tongue twisted tyrant
it was actually birdie hey you know I
just like the way you doing stuttering I
like Lisa that are I'll take it I'll
take it was Richard very favorite I love
it Ryan which Steven Spielberg movie
contains the line everybody runs pledge
1941 Minority Report or the terminal
1941 that was actually Minority Report
which Tim Burton movie contained the
line we come for your daughter Chuck
beetlejuice yes it's a weird line yeah
they clearly didn't come it was Chuck
Ryan which Chris or Reeves Superman
movie had the line you always want to
fly Kent now is your chance
yeah cuz that's what they called it the
first one it's a pokémon's it's just
what they put there so arrogant that
they call it the first one no I'm not
surprised you got it was Superman 3 that
nobody saw that's why I could surpass
himself on fire met in the series finale
of mash BJ Hunnicutt left Hawkeye Pierce
a note what did it say goodbye yes Ryan
in Rocky which two characters had the
following dialogue it's a living it's a
waste of life rocky and his wife's
brother know was actually rocky and
Mickey met in Saving Private Ryan what
our Tom Hanks final words to methane urn
I'll give it to you it's earned it um
okay earned there's a plane to fly sober
earnest B Gracie put the bottle there
Ryan in Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade
what does Harrison Ford say when his dad
says I didn't know you could fly I don't
that's your baby boy huh I don't I mean
we're both know it was actually fly yes
lamb know like the real hair is
important Matt which men in black movie
contains the line do you have any idea
how much that stings first men in black
yes I guess that's Superman so I want to
see Ryan in Brokeback Mountain who was
the character that could not make it on
a couple of high-altitude one or
twice a year
b-flat drop it's just the point give up
the boys it's just it's like baby fain
going through puberty mommy I can see
you adaptive at all Matt which movie has
the song lyric sit down John sit down
John for God's sakes
John sit down 1776 wow that's one of
those I'm reading it and my thumb's
covering the answer I'm like what 1941
is it gone very similar I'm sure Ryan in
what movie did Will Smith say you know
what you drive almost slow enough to
drive Miss Daisy blast you know that
movie is so stupid
but even that movie wouldn't be stupid
enough to make a reference to Driving
Miss Daisy she didn't exist yet it was
actually bad boys too clearly our young
men and are going to remain because that
is the buzzer ending the round if we
take a look we see that Ryan you have 50
points met you have 90 so Ryan I'm so
sorry you're after the dark and now you
will live
you can even make that out off you go my
friend
yes first you shoot me in my heart not
this show so much there you go there you
go it was a good attempt it kind of
sounds like a made in that movie
something he got something I'll shut
that doctor thank you yes we will be
right back what's up final round after
that contestant a pop quiz hot shot and
live in the Chicagoland area send a
video via YouTube stating your name a
and why you think it would be a good
contestant
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Matt's
congratulations
you'll be badly against a nostalgia
critic on our final round I'll be
reading seven questions whoever answers
the most questions correctly will win
this world peace the mug a very strange
item indeed but there it is also 150
dollars in cash and of course you're
live Oh beautiful all right I'll be
reading a group of Christmas movie
quotes you'll have to match the quote
with the movie critic are you ready that
was born ready for this match are you
ready yes let's begin
Matt correct critic you shoot your eye
out kid Christmas story correct Matt how
could you have a Christmas without the
Christmas tree mom incorrect it was home
alone to critic and you know when you're
telling these little stories here's a
good idea have a point that is
technically a Thanksgiving Day movie but
I would still say Planes Trains in our
movie correct Matt there's children
throwing snowballs instead of throwing
heads what's this what's this
it's a nightmare before christmas
correct critic arthur christmas is not a
time for emotion
correct Matt you guys give up are you
thirsty for more at home alone correct
critic so the big four are all here
Santa Claus to ferry the Sandman and the
Easter kangaroo Santa Claus - incorrect
Matt if something should happen to me
put on my suit the reindeer will know
what to do the Santa Claus correct
critic Santa Claus never lie is Joe
Santa moving correct Matt the thing
about trains it doesn't matter where
they're going
what matters is deciding to get on the
Polar Express correct critic hey
Griswold where do you think you're gonna
put a tree that big national influence
present thinking correct Matt your honor
a lot of people believe mr. Kringle
including millions of children Miracle
on 34th Street correct
and finally critic I am one with the
Yuletide
me we're gonna say Christmas correct and
the winner is simply someone loves
Christmas almost perfectly as me all
right I guess we got a rock paper
scissors yeah all right the second time
I'm doing this okay you ready one two
three Christmas champion I'm gonna break
and I'll see you next time on pop quiz
hotshot did the same to get you those
buttons oh yeah yeah some of us yeah
yeah for promotion every single time
really that's right Wow so you work for
Santa yeah that's amazing
potentially I mean it's a it's a great
job right nice way I get to open up some
toys the kids are gonna be opening up
later on in order to get a sneak peek
and all that they're wow do you put in
like a little ammunition in there too
and stuff like that that's cool yeah I
can start while they're young right yes
indeed so does he still have elves are
they enslaved or older more like people
who really use them from like on a
faraway Island I feel a cheaper to they
usually work for free oh yeah yeah yeah
I never like you know laughter or hug
something like that
[Music]